and boy you can never
overestimate the intelligence of drivers
they think they can drive right through
a barricade let me show you what we're
talking about so sahara is closed
between jones and torrey pines which is
over towards rainbow we'll have a detour
for you in just a second but here's a
live picture uh we had hector reporting
live over at jones here's at torrey
pines so literally just a minute ago a
pickup truck driving south on torrey
pines think oh good i'm going to turn
left and he went walking he's like going
to turn left right here he didn't just
don't you see the flashing lights and
just a couple of minutes before that
someone thought they were sneaky
northbound on torrey pines hey i bet you
if i go through the parking lot here of
the credit union and i go by the sonic
i'll bet you i can get on sahara are you
kidding me there are police here it's
closed so that driver got turned around
and just kind of tiptoed out of the way
folks when you see police and they're
blocking your street i don't know if you
know this but that means the road is
closed
don't try to go through a police
barricade for east west travel with
sahara close go up to oaky or down to
desert we're watching all the freeways
for you all morning long